pour évoquer ce scandale président du
club de l'information africaine louis
keumayou
bonjour louis keumayou merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation qu'elle est la
résonance de cette enquête en rdc voire
même en afrique de manière générale
je crois que ça cette enquête viennent
mettre le doigt sur un phénomène qui
depuis plusieurs années déjà est relevé
par les ong on a eu affaire des biens
mal acquis qui avait déjà été soulevée
est une affaire de mobutu sese seko dont
on disait que la fortune équivaut à la
bête de du zaïre de l'époque qui est
devenue la rdc aujourd'hui donc ce n'est
pas un phénomène nouveau que de
découvrir que la rdc est un pays très
riche afin potentiellement mais dont les
richesses ont pillé par les dirigeants
ce qui est important ici c'est de
comprendre les mécanismes mais au delà
d'elle et aussi dans dans le sens de
restaurer les droits des congolais par
rapport à ce pillage dont ils ont été
victimes parce que en l'état actuel des
choses et c'est vrai quoi nos premiers
ils jouent vous parlez des congolais
justement comment est-ce qu'elle réagit
la population congolaise ce qu'il faut
craindre une révolte populaire
elle est accrue je ne pense pas qu'elle
se produira maintenant parce que ce que
nous constatons c'est qui a
on est on est pas loin d'une d'échéances
électorales les conditions d'élection du
président actuel ont été très contestées
la ceni elle-même est contesté puisque
certains disent que l'argent de la ceni
a été également détourné dans le cadre
de cette enquête c'est ce que révèle
cette enquête donc l'idée c'est de voir
si cela pourra changer la donne mais au
regard du rapport de force je crains
malheureusement que non parce que qu'il
s'agisse des biens mal acquis ou de
cette affaire de combos holder je n'ai
pas l'impression que cela a changé
quelque chose dans la puissance de ceux
qui sont déjà au pouvoir ou dans leurs
rapports avec les populations pas de
réaction de la communauté internationale
union africaine-onu paris washington
bruxelles vont-ils communiqué selon vous
et est-ce que ce scandale peut avoir des
répercussions au niveau diplomatique
non quand vous voyez comment les
dossiers sur les paradis fiscaux sont
traités je crains malheureusement que ce
soit juste une énième affaire un
scandale de plus il y avait eu les
lumumba peppers avant cette publication
à laquelle dont nous sommes au début de
la publication ce sont les scandales qui
informe les gens sur des choses qu'ils
soupçonnaient mais dont ils n'avaient
pas le détail là ils ont quelques
éléments de détail pendant les quinze
prochains jours qu'ils en auront
davantage encore mais je crains
malheureusement que cela ne change pas
grand chose à la donne
concrètement qu'est ce que risque le
clan kabila avec joseph kabila qui
dément
il ne risque pas grand chose je crois
que la seule chose qu'ils risquent
aujourd'hui et qui si ce produit déjà
c'est le discrédit qui est jeté sur le
nom c'est le fait que même si dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochains
jours leur avocat monte au créneau et
que eux mêmes monte au créneau leurs
paroles ne sera pas cru mais ils ne sont
pas les seuls parce que encore une fois
les enquêteurs disent que même les
personnes qui sont pouvoir actuellement
sont touchés par ce phénomène et que les
révélations tout rond les concernés donc
il n'y a pas que la famille kabyle 1 les
montants sont impressionnants quand on
met cela sur tous les chefs de la
pauvreté du pays c'est très très
inquiétant mais je crains
malheureusement ça n'apporte pas grand
chose et que même au niveau des retours
parce que rappelons-nous l'argent de
kadhafi n'est jamais devenu l'argent des
biens mal acquis n'est jamais revenu
dans les pays concernés et les les
paradis fiscaux reste aujourd'hui un
domaine où les pays ne veulent pas
légiférer montcalm et ils légifèrent ils
légifèrent vraiment à la baisse et les
lanceurs dallaire ne sont pas toujours
suffisamment protégé je prends un juste
deux exemples avec les wikileaks et
d'autres événements vous verrez que sept
lanceurs d'alertés y compris en occident
ne sont pas suffisamment protégés donc
espérons que cela puisse changer la
mentalité mais ce que je pressens qu'on
aura c'est que la chine est plutôt les
techniques à la fois de détournements et
de transfert de ces fonds vers les
paradis fiscaux justement il y à une
banque qui est mise en cause qui est
pointée du doigt dans ce scandale il
s'agit de l'établissement bancaire b gfi
banques elle est surnommée la banque des
présidents
oui parce que c'est d'abord qui a été
accusé déjà dans le dossier des biens
mal acquis par rapport aux caps ont au
congo et la guinée équatoriale
c'était surtout le volet gabonais qui
concernait la bgfibank mais je pense que
toutes les banques procèdent ainsi alors
sans doute si l'on rentré dans le détail
on se rendrait compte que la bg fier
n'est pas la seule banque embarqué dans
ce genre de pratique ce que cela prouve
c'est que l'afrique est entrée dans la
mondialisation et qu'elle doit se donner
les moyens de contrôler les dérives par
rapport à ce que permet cette
mondialisation c'est-à-dire la capacité
de faire circuler les fonds à une
vitesse phénoménale sens qui en contrôle
à proprement parler parce que même les
nations unies qui envoie de l'argent à
la rdc et qui ne peuvent pas les
contrôler c'est inquiétant est ce que
les pays ont aujourd'hui les moyens de
contrôler ces flux financiers
est ce que les institutions
internationales et les pays peuvent se
donner la main ou garantir que l'argent
qui est injecté dans les économies sera
surveillé espérons le mais la bg fier et
peut-être celle qui a été prise par la
patrouille seront rentrés dans le détail
je crains qu'on en trouve un peu plus
que la bg est fier et que les montants
soient souvent un peu plus important vu
ce que représente aujourd'hui les
trafics en rdc et dans toutes les
régions de l'afrique centrale merci nous
et que maillot et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
président du club de l'information
africaine c'est la fin de